robert p jones is the ceo of the public
religion research institute and also
author of the new book white too long
the legacy of white supremacy
in american christianity uh robert
thanks for your time really appreciate
it oh
thanks yeah i'm great i'm really glad to
be here so let's uh
just just just to get us into this topic
can you talk a little bit about i mean
how how far back
does the um interplay or overlap
between white supremacy and american
christianity go
and is it a specific to certain
denominations
that's a great yeah opener um well it
goes all the way back
um you know is the thing there is to say
i mean all the way back to the founding
of the republic and in fact
you know what the the version of uh kind
of particularly white protestant
christianity that lands on american
shores
um you know brings with it this
entanglement with white supremacy really
from its european
uh european roots um so things like
manifest destiny
the idea that white europeans are
entitled to native american lands
all the way from the very beginning i
mean these are very much wrapped up with
this entanglement of the idea that
kind of white uh white people are meant
to be over others in kind of a racial
hierarchy
and that this was legitimated by
christian belief and it kind of brought
and kind of came over legitimated and
packaged in
a kind of white christian theological
package
uh when we look at the um the northern
baptist
southern baptist split which is
something that has been written about
from a number of different angles over
the years um
how much was that split related to this
issue of white supremacy
yeah well it was it was the reason uh
really that
you know baptism north and baptist in
the south parted ways so it was
literally
over whether a uh ordained
member of the clergy could enslave other
human beings
on the basis of the color of their skin
and still you know retain their status
as a
as a clergy person and that whether this
was a legitimately christian
thing to do and baptism in the north
rejected that view baptist and the south
were so dedicated
uh to protecting um you know not only
this possibility but this as a christian
norm
that they literally split from their
northern brother and set up their own
you know convention called the southern
baptist convention that's where that
name comes from
uh in 1845 so this is well before um
even the civil war um this is my home
denomination i should say and that i
grew up
uh as a southern baptist in mississippi
um
and uh but you know that history i think
one of the reasons why i wrote the book
is um that history is not well known
really i mean even
even i growing up inside the church
didn't find out about it until i was in
seminary so my early
in my early 20s but the one thing to say
to answer the first part of your
question to
your first question is that while i
think this history
is most um kind of on the surface with a
with an organization like the southern
baptist convention
virtually every protestant denomination
split um over the issue of slavery and
white supremacy um in the civil war the
method is split
presbyterian split the episcopalians uh
you know spit
split um and it was all really over this
question
of the legitimacy of of slavery and then
underneath that the kind of you know
bigger
thing that um that justifies that this
idea
of white of white supremacy it is or to
what degree is the catholic church sort
of
exempt from this i mean i know you said
that this was predominantly um
in in protestant churches but what about
the catholic church
right uh really important as well i mean
what we find is that um you know
despite the fact that the catholics have
their own history of discrimination
you know in in the us there's a lot of
anti-catholic sentiment
you know as late as john f kennedy's um
you know presidential election
he was facing a lot of anti-catholic uh
sentiment in in 1960 but um
you know it is worth saying too that but
in the latter years um this this problem
really exists
it actually exists you know through the
catholic church as well so for example
even in new york
um you know not in the south uh but in
new york city
um you know there was one catholic
parish as african-americans begin to
move in numbers from the south to new
york
as part of the great migration they were
displacing in many cases
irish neighborhoods polish neighborhoods
italian neighborhoods
and pushing uh folks out and and they
actually left because they didn't want
to live alongside
um african-americans and and and then
even the the diocese in um
in new york designated one diocese saint
mark's parish
or one one parish saint mark's parish as
the
place for african americans to go so in
other words if you're white in new york
you could go to your local
hair school if you want to go to
catholic school but if you were
african-american there was one
school you had to go to they had
segregated all african-americans into
one school
african-americans often had to wait uh
uh at the end of the line
until all whites had received the
eucharist at a mass
before they could receive eucharist and
this is again in catholic churches in
new york
uh so it really has infected really not
only kind of
evangelicals in the south or mainline
protestants in the midwest but also
catholics
that are more numerous in urban and
northeastern settings
i'm guessing that the answer to this
question i'm guessing there are multiple
answers to this question that that may
vary but
what have been some of the biblical
justifications
for for slavery and then short of
slavery discrimination or out outward
racism
yeah um you know i spent a whole chapter
in the book talking about the kind of
theology and kind of how this creeps in
and is embedded in in white christian
theology one of the most
blatant examples really is that white
christians really invented a separate
creation story
for black and brown people that was
separate from the creation story
uh for white people so uh and and
read this back into the book of genesis
and uh it was in the story of um
cain and abel these are um two brothers
cain kills his brother abel because he's
jealous and then lies to god about the
murder
and in the in the text it says that god
marks him kind of
it marks him as a result now the text
doesn't say anything about skin color
or race or any of that but white
theologians and clergy
and white christians in general read
back into that passage aha here's the
beginning
of dark-skinned people that's their
origin story
now that conveniently right traces then
whites back to adam and eve to these
kind of more noble human beings
uh that god formed by god's own hands
and breathed life into them
uh and then traces the origin story of
uh
non-white peoples in the world literally
to a criminal act
um that is that is the you know to a
murder um and so
it it it sets up a kind of not only kind
of racial hierarchy but a moral
hierarchy
with whites having this more noble
history and non-whites having this
um you know history that again goes back
to an original ancestor
who is literally a murderer more
recently
um and but you know during the 20th
century so to speak
we started to see groups like the kkk
come to prominence in certain parts of
the country
and the the the identity of the kkk
as a christian group is something that
is much discussed and to different
extents
debated but as my understanding uh uh
remains today they at least
self-identify
as as a christian group can you talk a
little bit
about that and the relationship between
the kkk and particular denominations
uh sure you know they it it's worth
noting
that that's exactly right that the kkk
um was
very um explicitly christian um they and
and to be very specific
they were protestant christian um right
so what's what's lost often is
you know people think about them burning
crosses against african-americans in the
country but
uh what's worth remembering is that they
were not only an anti-black organization
but they also saw jews and catholics as
a threat
uh to a protestant america that they
were out to defend i mean they were very
explicitly
defending a white anglo-saxon protestant
version of america um and you know so
and so they they were yeah they they
were very vehemently anti-catholic saw
them as a threat to democracy and
anti-jewish
um you know as well uh so a lot of
anti-semitism
and anti-catholicism you know really
traces its way back there
and i think the thing that that survives
and sort of like is more diffuse
in in particularly white protestant
circles is this is this melding
of white anglo-saxon protestantism with
american identity
right i think that this is one of the
things we're still struggling with today
that that white christians in many ways
and particularly white protestants
historically saw themselves as
america right um and and and so the with
the changing demographics of the country
today
uh white christians today for example um
are only 44
of the country that's if you take all of
them together and just a decade ago they
were 54
percent of the country so this is a
quite recent sea change that we've been
through
and i think some of the um visceral
things in our politics and particularly
i think
the appeal of of trump when he has
talked to white christians in particular
has been to appeal to this white
anglo-saxon protestant version of
america that he
is standing in to protect uh from change
as the country is shifting
um quite dramatically over the last 10
or 15 years
last thing i want to touch on speaking
now in in the modern era you know in the
right now
and over the last 10 to 15 years what is
the landscape like
in terms of denominationally the sort of
more
uh integrated and uh progressive for
lack of a better term
protestant denominations versus on the
other side the ones that still maintain
more of the segregation and division
yeah well you know i'd like to say they
were that that i had found in my
research
a great deal more distinction than i in
fact found
i think is one of the more surprising
findings of the book is that
despite the fact that if you look at the
denominational level and you look at
like statements for example the
denominations have put out
the mainline protestant denominations
that are part of the national council of
churches for example have put out
lots of statements about racial justice
about black lives matter
those kinds of things that if you just
read those statements you would think
that the domination is
those denominations are kind of way over
here yeah um whereas you've heard much
less from
the national association of evangelicals
for example um and and other evangel
the southern baptist convention other
other groups you've heard much less from
them
but the thing is if you get away from
those elite actors and you look at
actually people in the pews
as we've done in national public opinion
surveys um just
real quickly example i developed in the
book a thing i called a racism index
which is a measure of
attitudes about structural racism across
15 different questions
and if you use a metric like that and i
scored that index on a scale of one to
ten
um it's maybe not that surprising with
10 being holding the most racist
attitudes that white evangelicals score
eight out of ten
um on that index but here's what's
surprising is that white mainline
protestants again these are
episcopalians and presbyterians uh
the united stand on that same index and
as did white catholics white catholics
scored seven
out of ten and if you take whites who
are not um religiously and
are not christian they only score four
um out of ten on the same index so the
big divider really
among white americans today is christian
identity and christian identity moves
average white people further away
actually from the concerns of racial
justice that african americans have have
in the country
that was one of the more remarkable i
think finding the book is just that
distance
uh and and that it is really it is
christian identity that really is doing
the work
of kind of moving uh whites um who are
christians
further away um from the concerns of
african-americans than whites who are
not
that's it do you out of curiosity do you
have numbers on that scale for for
example
uh mormons jews and muslims
so um we don't have enough for mormons
they weren't big enough to break out and
we don't have enough
for jews and muslims individually but
when we break out we put together like
non-christian religious people so jews
muslims hindus buddhists
i don't remember the numbers straight up
but they are further much further down
the scale than white christians are
um on these questions much more
sympathetic to the views of african
americans and racial justice
issues um that aren't then are white
christians so white christians are
really staking out
the higher end of that um sticking out
the higher end of that scale
that's uh that that's absolutely
fascinating the the book is
white too long the legacy of white
supremacy
in american christianity we've been
speaking with the book's author
robert p jones who's also ceo of public
religion research institute
robert i so appreciate your time today
oh thanks for having me great to talk to
you